The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational
resources for free.
To make a donation or view
additional materials from
hundreds of MIT courses, visit
MIT OpenCourseWare at
ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: OK, let's
get started.
Everyone can go ahead and take
10 more seconds on today's
clicker question.
This is about hybridization,
which we will go over more to
start today, but just
to see where we are
as a starting point.
All right, great.
So most of you got this.
The question is what was the
hybridization of an atom if we
know that it has two
hybrid orbitals.
This is really, really
important, so I'm just going
to write this out for that 20%
of you that didn't see this
right away.
So we know that when we have
hybrid orbitals that come from
s and p orbitals, these are our
atomic orbitals we have to
choose from to hybridize.
So if we know, for example,
that we need two hybrid
orbitals, that means we needed
to have started with two
atomic orbitals.
So that means what we would
form are two s p hybrid
orbitals and we'd be left
with our other two p
orbitals left over.
So any time you figure out that
you're going to need two
hybrid orbitals, and we'll go
over when you would find this
out in just a minute, but any
time that happens you know it
has to come from an s and a p,
so that's why you'll end up
with s p hybrid orbitals
there.
And exam 2 is happening in just
one week from today, so
next Wednesday.
The semester moves really fast.
So I can't believe we're
already up to exam 2
talk, but we are.
So, you should have all received
two handouts when you
walked in today, your notes and
then an exam 2 info sheet.
Did everybody get that?
If you didn't get it, just raise
your hand and a TA will
come to you with that.
I see there's a few around, if
one of the TA's can jump up
and fill those in.
All right, so basically,
as with exam 1, all the
information you need to know
about what's going to be on
exam 2 is on this handout.
Specifically exam 2
is going to cover
lectures 10 through 17.
Today is lecture 16, so that
means it's going to cover
today's lecture and then a bit
into Friday's lecture as well,
so I'll be really clear on
Friday where exam 2 material
ends, where you can kind of
switch off the exam 2 part of
your studying.
And it will also be on
problem-sets 4 and 5.
So it's going to be on two
problem-sets instead of three
problem-sets, but as you know,
there are a lot of different
concepts covered in these
two problem-sets.
So it's still a lot to be
thinking about and you need to
make sure that you really
understand all of these
different concepts.
So this is explicitly listed
in this sheet here, so make
sure you look it over.
But I just want to say is well,
the concepts that we've
covered since exam 1 have been
talking about covalent bonds,
going along with that are all
the Lewis structures that
we've done.
Then we talked about ionic
bonds, so you need to make
sure you can solve those ionic
bond problems. And then we
started talking about different
types of bonding in
terms of thinking about MO
theory, and also vesper theory
and hybridization.
And then today, and a little
bit on Friday, you'll be
responsible for some of this new
material, which is going
to be a little bit of
thermochemistry.
Not too much on exam 2, most of
that will be saved for exam
3 material, but an intro to
thermochemistry, that will
also be on the exam, just as
far as these two lectures.
So, basically this is all
written out here, and I also
want to mention in terms of
your MO diagrams and MO
theory, I sent out an email
about this, but I also wrote
it out here so you have it
written down in terms of what
you are responsible for in terms
of ordering the energy
levels of molecular orbitals.
So that's all written down
explicitly right here, this is
what you need to know
for the exam.
Also it's helpful for the
problem-set as well.
And also, in terms of MO
diagrams, I think that you
will already gone over this
pretty explicitly either last
week in recitation or yesterday,
in terms of what
you need to do to get full
credit when you're actually
drawing an MO diagram.
Just in case you don't have that
information or you didn't
write it down, I wrote this down
for you here as well in
terms of things like making
sure to draw your energy
arrows, or remembering
to label all
of your atomic orbitals.
We don't want anyone getting
points off on the exam for
doing something silly where
they do understand what's
going on, but they're
just not writing it
in the correct form.
So all this information
is on your sheet here.
And also on this sheet mentions
that you will be
getting optional extra
problems on Friday.
This is just like for exam 1.
The way that you should approach
these extra problems,
you don't need to turn them in,
you're not required to do
them, but if you want to do well
on the exam we really,
really encourage that you do
these problems. And in terms
of having it be worth your time
when you're solving these
problems, what you want to do
is make sure you're at the
point where you can put your
notes away, where you can sit
alone without your friends,
and really approach these
extra problems as if they're
exam problems. This way if
there's some conceptual leap
that you haven't quite made
yet, but you don't realize it
because you've been using your
notes or using the conversations
with your
friends, you want to make that
leap and run into those
problems alone in your room
when you have two hours to
figure it out.
You don't want to do this
leap on an exam.
That's not the ideal
situation.
So especially with Lewis
structures where sometimes you
can run into confusions that you
need to work through and
make sure it all makes sense in
terms of your head how to
do this, make sure you take the
time to do that before the
exam and don't have to end up
struggling with that on the
exam in a time situation.
All right, so the extra problem
solutions will be
posted on Sunday.
And in terms of office hours for
next week, my office hours
are going to be on Monday from
2 to 4, I'm moving them up,
and your TAs will move up their
office hours as well, so
check with them in recitation
or on the website.
So that's pretty much
it for exam 2.
Are there any questions about
what you're responsible for or
anything regarding exam 2?
OK, and in terms of the room
it's in Walker again, so at
least this part should
be familiar.
You'll be used to going to your
row, it'll be the same
row, it's all written here
again, but you can just do
exactly what you
did for exam 1.
All right, so one last class
announcement, and this is that
if you've been looking at our
first sheet of the whole year,
sort of the course overview
sheet, you know that our class
in terms of grading is out of
750 points, and 50 of those
points are for attendance and
something called occasional
in-class quizzes.
So what we're going to do is
start filling in some of those
points because we only have 36
classes worth of attendance.
So we have a couple of points
to make up in terms of
quizzes, and these are going to
be clicker quizzes, and let
me explain how this
is going to work.
Basically, in at least for my
part of the class, what we're
going to do, because what I
really care about is that
people are answering the clicker
questions, it's really
valuable for me.
I don't necessarily care if you
get them right or wrong
during class, because this is
the point at which you're
still learning them.
So these quiz points, which
could be up to 2 points per
class, will be in addition to
attendance points, and you'll
get full credit if you answer
the quiz question.
So you need to be answering
the questions because the
quizzes will not be announced.
So this is another reward for
people that are always
participating.
These clicker questions are
really valuable to us in terms
of the feedback, it really gives
me an idea of where the
class is as a whole.
So really, it's important that
you are answering these
questions and this is a way to
get your quiz points up, so in
addition to attendance, you'll
get 2 quiz points.
We'll have our first unannounced
quiz today, so you
won't know what problem it is
beforehand, so I suggest you
make sure you're answering all
the clicker questions, which
most of you do anyway.
And I will just say I recognize
that some of you are
just scurrying across campus
to get here on time.
So I'll never make that first
question a quiz question,
because I know how hard it is
to get from one place to
another on this campus, and I
know most of you do a great
job of sneaking in right at the
last minute when you have
that long run.
So we won't make the first
question a quiz question, but
be on the look out for a
quiz question today.
All right.
So let's get to today's topic.
We're going to finish talking
about valence bond theory and
hybridization.
So what we've already done is
really cover all the theory
that we're going to cover
behind how hybridization
works, and behind how valence
bond theory works.
But what we haven't covered is
how do we actually solve
problems doing this in
the really quick way.
So we're going to do that.
This is going to be a more
practical lesson in
hybridization.
And once we do that, we'll move
on to now talking about
energies and enthalpies
of chemical reactions.
So this is a real shift.
We spent a while talking about
single atoms, and then we've
spent most of the material,
since exam 1,
talking about bonding.
So now we're taking it one step
further and we're going
to actually get to talk about
some chemical reactions.
So we'll do that once we
finish up with our
hybridization unit here.
All right, so how do we
go about determining
hybridization in complex
molecules?
It's actually incredibly simple,
and all that you need
to do is think about for the
given atom that you're looking
at, what you want to do is add
up the number of atoms that
are bonded to your central
atom, or the atom you're
considering, and add to that
the number of lone pairs.
And what you end up with is the
number of hybrid orbitals
that you need.
All right, so the theory behind
hybridization and
picturing everything, that can
be pretty complicated, and I
do want you to understand
that.
But if, for example, on an
exam situation, you don't
necessarily have to think
through everything, you can
just use this very quick way
to figure out the number of
hybrid orbitals that you need.
And what we just said is that
any time we need two hybrid
orbitals, we know that the
hybridization of that atom is
going to be s p, because
it's made up of
one s and one p orbital.
So let's say we need three
hybrid orbitals.
What is our hybridization of
our atom in this case?
Yeah, it's s p 2.
We want to take three atomic
orbitals to make three hybrid
orbitals, so it's going
to be s p 2.
So what if we need four hybrid
orbitals, what's the
hybridization going to
be in this case?
STUDENT: S p 3.
PROFESSOR: S p 3.
All right, great.
So, really that's it.
Hopefully hybridization just got
a lot simpler for any of
you that have been struggling
a little bit with it.
But let's go ahead and do an
example to make sure that we
can all do this.
And let's take a look --
first let me mention
an exception here.
The one exception to thinking
about how many hybrid orbitals
that you have are in the case
where you have single bonded
terminal atoms. So in the case
of a terminal atom that is a
single bond, you're not
going to hybridize it.
So in that case, just don't even
change anything it's just
going to be one of the p
orbitals, or unless you're
talking about hydrogen in
which case will be an s
orbital that overlaps.
All right, so we can illustrate
this with an
example of formal chloride.
So this is a good example
because we're just dealing
with our carbon as our central
atom here, and we have three
terminal atoms, two of which
are single bonded, so we're
not going to hybridize those,
and one which is double
bonded, the oxygen, so we
will hybridize that one.
So in terms of thinking about
the carbon, what is a
hybridization around
the carbon atom?
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: All right, I'm
hearing some mixed answers.
So let's think.
So the carbon atom is bonded to
three different atoms, and
it has no lone pairs.
So what's the hybridization?
STUDENT: S p 2.
PROFESSOR: Good s p 2.
So, if we're talking about the
c h bond, we're going to say
that it's carbon, it's a sigma
bond because it's a single
bond, and then it's carbon
2 s p 2 bonded to a
hydrogen 1 s orbital.
All right, so let's take
a look at the carbon
chlorine bond here.
Again, carbon is still 2 s p 2,
it's the same carbon atom,
and it's going to be a sigma
bond because it's a single
bond, but what about the
chlorine, what atomic orbital
is going to be bonding
in the chlorine?
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: All right.
I'm hearing a little bit of
mixes, they're all p's, which
is a good start.
It turns out that it's going
to be the chlorine 3 p z.
So the reason that it's p is
because we're not hybridizing
it, and the reason that I
specifically say that it's the
p z instead of the p x or the
p y, is remember that the
z-axis, that's our bonding
axis, that's our
internuclear axis.
So any time we have a p orbital
that's involved in a
sigma bond, it has to be the z
orbital because that's the
only one that has the right
orientation to overlap along
that z-axis.
So we're going to say it's
carbon s p 2, and then
chlorine 3 p z.
All right, so let's look at the
last bond here, which is a
carbon oxygen double bond.
We know that any time we have a
double bond it's made up of
one sigma bond plus
one pi bond.
So, when we look at the carbon
again, that's 2 s p 2.
But what about the oxygen,
what's the hybridization of
this oxygen atom?
S p 2.
So we're going to have carbon
2 s p 2, and then
oxygen 2 s p 2.
It's s p 2 because the oxygen is
bonded to one atom plus two
lone pairs, so we're going
to have a total of
three hybrid orbitals.
All right, so this is not our
only bond, we have a double
bond, so we also need to
talk about the pi bond.
So if we talk about the pi bond,
we can say that's carbon
2 p y, then the oxygen 2 p y.
We could alternatively say, and
be correct, that it was
the carbon 2 p x and
the oxygen 2 p x.
Either one of those is fine.
All right, so that's an example
of how we can assign
very quickly and very easily
what the hybridization is of a
given atom.
And then also fully describe the
symmetry and the atomic or
hybrid orbitals that
make up bonds.
So this is a lot of your
problems on the p-set, so if
you haven't finished that
section, hopefully you'll be
able to get through that section
pretty quickly when
you go back to it.
And let's take a look at a
little bit of a more complex
molecule here, which is ascorbic
acid or vitamin C.
And this is a good example
because it's starting to look
a little more complicated, but
not too much more complicated.
But the reality is if you know
how to do assigning the
hybridization this way, even
if I gave you a 1,000 atom
protein, you should still
be able to get
it completely correct.
Vitamin C is a really important
molecule to actually
think about in terms of thinking
about its shape and
its hybridization.
Vitamin C is an antoxidant.
So we might remember that from
when we were talking about
free radicals.
Free radicals can cause
oxidative damage.
These antioxidants, some of
our vitamins, including
vitamin C are antioxidants.
So that's something that a lot
of people in the general
population know if they're
into their health.
But another really important
thing about ascorbic acid is
that it's an enzyme cofactor.
And a cofactor just means that
it's some type of molecule or
atom, in this case it's a
molecule, that's required by
an enzyme in order
for the enzyme to
carry out its chemistry.
And the chemistry that the
enzymes that vitamin C are a
cofactor for are responsible
for putting oxygen, o h
groups, onto collagen molecules
in order to form
what is the collagen
triple helix.
And collagen is the main
constituent of bones, of
joints, of connective tissue,
of many important structural
parts of our bodies.
So you can imagine that vitamin
C is very important
because we need to keep
our collagen intact.
Collogen is actually one of the
most prevalent proteins in
our entire body, and it makes up
a large part of our cells.
So you can imagine if we don't
have collagen that is in this
triple helix, we're going to run
into some problems. Does
anyone, or I'm sure many of you
do know, but can someone
tell me what the name is of
the disease if you have a
deficiency in vitamin C?
STUDENT: Scurvy.
PROFESSOR: Yeah, scurvy.
So scurvy, most often associated
with ships because
of the 1500's and 1600's and
1700's when boating technology
was far above biochemistry
technology, so people could
make ships and go on these long
journeys, but people did
not yet understand they needed
to keep certain vitamins in
their bodies, such as vitamin
C. Maybe also, they didn't
know about -- well they didn't
even have the structure, so
they couldn't have realized that
vitamin C is polar and
won't stay in their bodies for
very long, it will get
excreted out through
their urine.
So they were not thinking about
how quickly they could
run into trouble in the
long sea voyages.
And I don't know how many of you
had a unit on explorers in
elementary school --
I did in fifth grade, and one
that always sticks in my head
is Magellan's trip around the
world, who led the first fleet
of ships around the globe.
What they did not mention to us
in fifth grade was that 90%
of his men died on
that journey.
And I understand we were young
kids, I didn't want to know
that at the time, but it's
interesting and it's really
important, and the reason
for many of
these deaths was scurvy.
And it's totally preventable.
And, in fact, the cure for
scurvy, which is as simple as
taking vitamin C in any form,
was known for -- since the
fifth century people started
figuring this out, but the
problem was there was so much
false information as well that
it was not a general practice
on ships to be treating men
that were suffering with vitamin
C or using it as any
kind of preventative measure.
The other somewhat interesting
thing I want to say about
vitamin C is that it was part
of the first ever published
clinical study.
And this was a controlled
clinical study that was done
in the 1700's, the first one
that's ever been reported, and
not surprisingly it was done on
a ship and it was done by
James Lind who was a Scottish
naval surgeon.
And basically, he took 12 of
his men, so this was not a
very large clinical study like
they do today, but he took 12
men that were suffering from
scurvy, and he gave them a
diet mostly of just carbohydrate
mush, because
when you have scurvy, one of
the first signs is bleeding
gums and teeth falling
out, they couldn't
really eat too much.
But he supplemented
their diet.
He put them in pairs of two and
supplemented with 1 of 6 things.
So two of them got a
pint of cider a day
to see if that helped.
Two of them got half a pint of
seawater -- maybe not the best
group to be in.
Even worse group to be in is
two of them got diluted
sulfuric acid.
Tuned out that didn't
help so well.
Other things where some got
spices, not so bad.
And then two of them actually
got citrus fruit.
So no big surprise ending to
this clinical study, the
people with citrus fruit were
completely cured and back to
duty within a week, and I'm not
sure exactly what happened
to everyone else, but
let's hope they got
switched over as well.
But it's just neat to think
about even back then, people
were doing these controlled
scientific studies, this was
one of the first cases.
Unfortunately, it was another
40 years between this study
being published and the
British Navy requiring
supplements of citric acid.
So, really, we've come a long
way in terms of disseminating
scientific knowledge to the
community, and that's a really
important part of being
scientists -- not just making
these discoveries, but also
passing along, for example, to
these ships full of people
that need to know it.
So, in terms of scurvy, we
don't see too much of it
today, but who should
be concerned about
suffering from scurvy?
Do we have to worry about our
cats or dogs at home, are they
getting enough of their
vegetables and vitamin C?
It turns out we don't
have to worry.
Primates are who should
be concerned.
So we need to be concerned,
other
primates need to be concerned.
It turns out that most other
mammals actually biosynthesize
vitamin C, so we don't have
to worry about most
of our pets at home.
Unless you have a guinea pig
and they don't, in fact,
biosynthesize vitamin C, so I
think they supplement most
guinea pig pellets with vitamin
C, but maybe keep an
eye on your guinea pig.
We primates and guinea pigs are
the only types of mammals
that don't actually
biosynthesize their vitamin C.
So again, vitamin C is a
cofactor, that means it needs
to bind to an enzyme, it means
that the shape of vitamin C
and the hybridization are going
to be really important.
So let's take a look and talk
about some of these carbon
atoms here.
And you can look at your
structure of vitamin C in your
class notes while you're doing
this, and first I want you to
tell me what the hybridization
is of that carbon a in the
vitamin C molecule.
And let's take 10 more
seconds on that.
OK, 78%.
We'll do another question
like this in a minute.
So if we can switch back
to the notes we'll
take a look at that.
I think we can get better, I
think we can get to the 90's
with these hybridization, we
just need to follow the rules.
So if we're thinking about
vitamin C and we're talking
about carbon a, how many things
is carbon a bonded to?
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: four things.
We have two hydrogen atoms,
an oxygen, and
then another carbon.
So that means we need, if it's
bonded to four things, we need
four different hybrid orbitals,
so it needs to be s
p 3 hybridized.
All right, let's try this again
but just shouting out,
what is the hybridization
of carbon b?
Good.
OK, I'm going to say that was
about 90% of you I heard,
which is excellent.
S p 3.
What about carbon c here?
Yup, s p 3 again.
Bonded to four things
it's s p 3.
What about carbon d?
S p 2, great.
Carbon e?
STUDENT: S p 2.
PROFESSOR: All right, and this
last one, the last 10% of you
can join in.
Carbon f?
Great, s p 2.
All right, so we can also think
about shape once we know
hybridization and how
many atoms a carbon
atom is bonded to.
What would we say that the
shape is of these s p 3
orbitals -- or the shape
of the carbon atom.
Yeah, it's tetrahedral.
So this is going to
be tetrahedral.
And what about carbon
d, e, and f?
What is the geometry of
carbon d, e, and f?
Good, trigonal planar.
All right.
So let's actually take this
one step further from just
talking about the hybridization
of the
individual atom.
Let's talk about a couple
of these bonds.
I won't go through
all of them.
I think you can get the idea
with just a few, but you can
go back and try all
of them later.
So let's start with thinking
about carbon b hydrogen bond.
Is this going to be a
sigma or a pi bond?
Sigma.
We know it's sigma, because any
time we have a single bond
it's a sigma bond.
So carbon b, we just said,
is carbon, it's
going to be 2 s p 3.
And then hydrogen, what's the
atomic orbital we're talking
about here?
1 s.
All right, great.
So let's take a look at another
one, let's look again
at carbon b, but now let's talk
about it bonding to its
oxygen there.
So again, are we going
to be talking about a
sigma or a pi bond?
A sigma bond, because again,
it's a single bond here.
So what we'll say again is
carbon 2 s p 3, and let's take
a look at this oxygen
that it's bound to.
Is this oxygen -- what is the
hybridization of this oxygen
right here?
What is it?
OK, good, it's s p 3.
It's bound to two atoms, plus it
has two lone pairs, that's
a total of four things.
So it needs to have three
different hybrid orbitals, so
we'll say it's oxygen 2 s p 3.
So let's skip to a different
carbon now, let's talk about
carbon d, specifically the
carbon d oxygen bond.
So let's do a clicker question
for this one.
Let's get into the 90's, if you
don't mind, this would be
very good to do.
It'll make me feel better
about you finishing your
problem-sets tonight.
So if you talk about the
symmetry and the hybrid or
atomic orbitals that contribute,
we're talking
about the c d oxygen bond.
So go ahead and look at
your notes and see
what that bond is.
We already identified the
hybridization of carbon d, so
we really just need to think
about the oxygen here.
All right, let's take
10 more seconds.
OK, I'll take that, 84%.
That's not bad.
So again, we're looking
at a sigma bond here.
It looks like the one people
got it confused with was
talking about oxygen
s p 2 versus s p 3.
Remember, you just need to look
at what it is actually
bound to, so for carbon d, the
oxygen's bound to two atoms
plus two lone pairs, so it's
going to be s p 3 hybridized.
So we'll call this a sigma bond
where we have carbon 2 s
p, now it's s p 2, and
oxygen 2 s p 3.
All right, let's take a look
at just one more here.
So, let's look at the carbon
d bond with carbon e.
So if we can switch back to the
class notes just to see
that, though you guys can see
it on your notes as well.
So in terms of that, we're
talking about a double bond
now, so we know that we have to
have one sigma bond and one
pi bond to completely describe
our double bond.
So for the sigma bond, again,
it's going to be
carbon 2 s p 2.
And now we're talking about
the other carbon.
What is the hybridization
of the other carbon?
Yup, s p 2.
So carbon 2 s p 2.
All right, but we're
not done there.
We also need to talk
about the pi bond.
So for the pi bond, we'll talk
about carbon 2 p y, and then
the second carbon 2 p y.
All right, so I filled in a few
more in your notes, so you
can maybe cover those up and
make sure that you get all of
those correct is a good self
test before you finish off any
in your problem-set.
Does anyone have any questions
about figuring out
hybridization?
Yes?
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: I'm sorry,
what is that?
In this bond here?
Oh, OK, that's a
good question.
So the question was why is there
not hybridization in
these p orbitals here.
So in order to form a double
bond, we need to have a pi
bond forms, and a pi
bond forms from two
unhybridized p orbitals.
And if you can kind of picture
those p orbitals, if our
molecules are this way and
they're coming up here, we
need to have electron density
above the bond
and below the bond.
So if they're hybrid, then
they're going to be spread out
into that tetrahedral
geometry.
We want to have them parallel to
each other and they need to
be the p bonds, they need
to be the p orbitals.
Does that makes sense?
So any time we have a double
bond, the pi part of the bond
is going to be p orbitals.
Yes?
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: No, absolutely not.
It would be absolutely correct
to put 2 p x and 2 p x here,
you just can't put z, because
that's the one that's going to
be involved in the sigma bond.
And the other important thing
is if you do put x for one,
you have to make sure you put
x in the other, because they
do need to be able to interact
with each other.
You can't have one x and one y,
but sure, you can have both
x or both y.
OK, so let's shift gears a
little bit and start talking
about bonding in terms of
chemical reactions.
So we're going to start today
with talking about bond
energies, and also something
called bond enthalpies.
And the first point is just to
bring us back to something
we're very familiar with.
When we talked about covalent
bonding, a concept that we
have been discussing is bond
dissociation energy.
That's just the energy that's
required to put into a
molecule in order to
break that bond.
This is something that we saw
when we were talking just at
the very beginning of our
unit on covalent bonds.
That energy difference is the
energy difference between when
we have the c h 4, if we're
talking about methane, versus
one of those hydrogen bonds
breaking, one of those c h
bonds breaking.
So we've talked in the past
about bond energy, but what I
want to introduce to you today
is a very related concept,
which is called bond enthalpy.
So that's delta h here is what
we call bond enthalpy.
So, this is talking about
instead of the change of
energy accompanied with a bond
breaking, we're talking about
a change in heat accompanied
with a bond breaking.
So whether when that bond breaks
it requires heat, or
whether it gives off heat when
you break that bond or talking
about a reaction.
That's what we're talking
about when we're
talking about enthalpy.
It turns out that enthalpy is,
in fact, very related to
energy, and we can relate it
with this equation here that
bond enthalpy is equal to bond
energy plus the change in
pressure times volume.
So we could, in fact, go back
and forth between bond
energies and bond enthalpies,
but the reality is if we're
talking about gases, which we
are in many cases, then what
we find is the difference
between bond enthalpy and bond
energy is only 1% to 2%.
So it's not very significant.
And, in fact, if we're talking
about solids or liquids, now
we can say that the difference
between bond energy and bond
enthalpy is going to
be negligible.
So, for the rest of this class
today, we're going to stop
talking about bond energy, which
I did just for a moment,
to orient you back to a
discussion that was familiar,
we're going to switch our
discussion to bond enthalpies.
One reason that we like to
talk about enthalpies is
unlike energy, which can be a
little bit more tricky, bond
enthalpies are easy
to measure.
It's easy to measure how much
heat a reaction gives off or
how much heat a reaction
takes in.
So we can also talk about
something, which is called the
standard bond enthalpy, so any
time you see this symbol here,
which looks like a knot, so it
looks like a delta h knot,
that refers to the standard
bond enthalpy.
Any time we we're talking about
a standard, whether it's
enthalpy or, as we'll see in
the next lecture, standard
entropy or a standard free
energy, we're just saying that
the molecules that we're talking
about are in their
standard states, which means
they're in their pure form.
If they're a gas it means
they're at one bar.
Usually this is referring
to room
temperature, so 298 kelvin.
It's often that when you look
up tables of different bond
enthalpies, you'll see them in
their standard state and it
will be at room temperature.
So if we talk about standard
bond enthalpy, let's talk
about what this is for these
c h bonds, which
we just saw in methane.
So if we're going from c h 4 to
breaking one of these c h
bonds, what we see is that
the bond enthalpy is 438
kilojoules per mole.
The fact that it's positive
tells us that we need to put
in that much heat into
the system in order
to break that bond.
So we now know the enthalpy of
a c h bond, but, of course,
methane is not the only
kind of c h bond
that you can envision.
We could talk about the c h
bond, for example, in ethane
or trifluoromethane or trichloro
or tribromomethane,
and what you'll find is that
the amount of enthalpy that
that reaction is associated with
depends on the exact type
of c h bond that you have. So,
for example, we can see that
we have slightly different,
not vastly different, but
slightly different changes in
enthalpy depending on which
kind of c h bond that
were breaking.
And what I want to point out
also is that all of these
delta h's, all of these
standard bond
enthalpies are positive.
Any time we have a positive
delta h, we call this an
endothermic reaction.
And again, endothermic
just means that the
reaction takes in energy.
It's very similar to what when
we're talking about energy
whether something's taken in
or released, whether it's
positive or negative.
If you have positive delta h,
it's endothermic, it takes in
heat in order for the
reaction to go.
So we can think about instead of
talking about all of these
individual c h bonds, instead
we can talk about what the
average value would be
for all c h bonds.
So we can say that the average
of any c h bond is 412
kilojoules per mole.
So you can imagine if you're
looking these things up in
terms of a reference table or
maybe in the appendix of your
textbook, it would be an
impossibly huge number of
pages to write every single
different kinds of c h bond.
So that's why instead they talk
about the average bond
enthalpies.
So for c h, again, that's 412,
and all of the enthalpies we
just saw fall within
about 8% of that.
And in your book you can look
up any type of bond that's
listed here.
So we saw c h is 412.
You can look up a c c bond, you
can look up a c c double
bond, a c c triple
bond, and so on.
And you'll note that what
these are are mean bond
enthalpies, so they're the
average of all different types
of c h bonds or c c bonds
that you can imagine.
So, you might be asking what's
so important about being able
to look up and think about
these different bond
enthalpies.
And the reason that it's
important is because if you're
looking at a reaction, no matter
how complicated that
reaction is, you can actually
figure out what the enthalpy
of the entire reaction is by
adding up all the individual
mean bond enthalpies of the
products, and all the
individual mean bond enthalpies
of their reactants
and thinking about the
difference between those two.
So we'll do that in just a
second, and the reaction that
we'll do it with is the
oxidation of glucose here.
So, c 6 h 12 o 6, one mole of
glucose plus six moles of
oxygen, gives us six moles
of carbon dioxide and
six moles of water.
So what we can find out, and
hopefully what we will match
up when we look at using the
different bond enthalpies, is
that the enthalpy of this entire
reaction is negative
2816 kilojoules per mole.
So in this case we're saying
that delta h is negative.
Does anyone know what
it's called
when delta h is negative?
Everyone knows, great.
So it's exothermic.
This is an exothermic reaction,
the reaction
releases heat.
So I just want to mention before
we go on, if you look
at almost any freshman chemistry
textbook, what
you'll find is this oxidation of
glucose reaction is used a
lot in talking about
thermochemistry.
And one reason it's talked about
is because it's very
convenient to talk about
something where we start with
one mole of glucose and end up
with 12 moles of products.
That's going to be helpful what
we're doing a practice
problem to see exactly how you
deal with it when there's
different numbers of moles.
But the other reason you always
see this reaction is
because it's an incredibly
important reaction.
The oxidation of glucose is
going on all the time in our
body, this is our main source
of energy for all animals.
So let's think a little bit
about why this reaction is so
important and so prevalent.
It turns out that if we're
talking about plants, plants
do the reverse reaction.
So plants take carbon dioxide
and water and they turn it
into glucose or energy for us,
energy stored in the bonds of
glucose plus oxygen.
So if we do the reverse
reaction, this is actually
going to require energy.
Where do plants get
this energy?
Yeah, this is just
photosynthesis here.
This is the photosynthesis
where plants are turning
carbon dioxide and water into
sugar and into oxygen.
So what happens when we eat
the plants or when we eat
animals that have eaten the
plants is that we perform the
reverse reaction now, which is
what I just showed you, the
oxidation of glucose.
And even though it's not the
products of the reaction that
are particularly valuable to us,
we just breathe out the c
o 2, and actually we'd rather
have less of that than more in
our environment, but what's
important here is instead the
energy or the enthalpy that's
given often in this reaction.
So as I said, this reaction
has a negative enthalpy of
2816 kilojoules per mole.
That's a lot of enthalpy
and a lot of energy.
So we actually end up using that
energy to fuel most of
what is going on
in our bodies.
So instead of storing it as
sugar, once we oxidize the
sugar, now we just store it as
ATP, and as you know, ATP is
the currency of energy
in the cells.
So this is why you see this
reaction again and again and
again in just about any
chemistry textbook that you
open up as sort of a
general reaction.
The reason it's used is it's
just so important and so
prevalent in terms of thinking
about our bodies and how we're
staying alive and
using energy.
All right, so let's go ahead and
use this as an example of
what we just said, which is
using the bond enthalpies of
the products and the reactants
to figure out the enthalpy of
the entire reaction.
So the way that we do this
is we add up all of the
individual mean bond enthalpies
of the reactants,
and we subtract from that all
of the individual bond
enthalpies of the products.
So we can think about what
this will tell us.
If you think about the fact if
the bonds are stronger in the
products than they were in the
reactants, you can go ahead
and click in and tell me if
you think we'll have a
negative or a positive
delta h here.
All right, let's take 10
more seconds on this.
OK, great, so negative is
correct and some people got
totally mixed up.
Didn't just get one thing --
so let's just focus on the
right answer to start with.
The correct answer is that
it's negative, it's an
exothermic reaction.
And actually, lets switch
to our class
notes to explain why.
And also, this was the quiz
question for today, so whether
you got the answer correct or
incorrect, you get full quiz
points if you did,
in fact, answer.
But let's still focus on the
right answer here and see why
it's correct.
So if we're talking about the
bonds being stronger in the
products, that basically means
that we ended up releasing a
lot of heat when we made those
bonds and the products, and we
didn't have to use up too much
of that heat to break all the
bonds and the reactants.
So that's why we say
that delta h
is going to be negative.
You could also just do it not
conceptually, just plugging it
into the equation, but it's
better to kind of understand
exactly why that is.
It's because it takes more
energy -- you gain more energy
forming the products
than you take
breaking up the reactants.
So if we have the opposite case
here, if the bonds are
stronger in the reactants, now
what we're going to find is
that the delta h of the reaction
is positive and what
you're dealing with is an
endothermic reaction.
So let's go ahead and do this
with our example of the
oxidation of glucose.
So, I've just written out the
glucose molecule so you can
see all of its individual bonds
here since we're going
to be using that information.
So let's start by talking
about the bonds that are
broken in terms of thinking
about all of
the reactants here.
So if we're talking about the
sugar molecule itself, what we
have is we have seven
c h bonds.
And if we add up all the o h
bonds, we have five of those.
How many c o single
bonds do we have?
What do people think?
Yeah. five c o single bonds.
What about c c single bonds?
five of those as well.
C o double bonds?
Just one c o double bond.
And then we have our oxygen
molecule to worry about and we
have six o o double bonds.
So if we add up all of the
bonds are broken, and we
subtract from that the bonds
that are formed, those
strengths, the c double bond
o, we have 12 of those.
And how many o h bonds
do we have?
Right, 12 as well.
So if we add up all the bonds
broken, what we end up with is
12,452 kilojoules per mole,
and it's talking about per
mole of glucose that's
oxidized.
And in terms of bonds formed,
what we see is 15,192
kilojoules per mole.
So all we need to do to figure
out the change in enthalpy,
and when it has this subscript
r here, I meant to mention,
that means the enthalpy
for the reaction.
We just subtract these bonds
here from the ones that we
ended up forming.
So basically, what we're saying
-- excuse me, these are
the ones that we broke.
It's 12,452 minus 15,192,
which we formed.
So we end up with an enthalpy of
reaction of negative 2,740
kilojoules per mole of glucose
that's oxidized.
All right, so if you remember
the number that I told you
before, it doesn't exactly match
up with what we had said
is the exact number.
The exact number is 2,816.
It is within 3% though,
that's pretty good.
Because remember, we're not
using exact bond enthalpies
here, what we were using is
average bond enthalpies.
So it makes sense that we're
going to be a little bit off.
But if all you have in front of
you is the information on
bond enthalpies, mean bond
enthalpies, this is a great
way to figure out the enthalpy
of an overall reaction.
We can think of a different way,
however, to think about
the enthalpy of an overall
reaction, and this is talking
about the heat of formation.
And the heat of formation or
delta h formation here is
equal to the heat of -- or the
enthalpy of reaction, if we're
talking about forming one mole
of compound from its pure
elements, which are in their
standard states.
So basically, there's a table
that you can look up which
tells you the enthalpy of
formation for any compound
that you're interested in, and
this is actually an appendix
to of your textbooks, and you
will need to use this to solve
your problems on p-set.
But let me say that, for
example, if we're talking
about water here, that's formed
from hydrogen and
oxygen, if we're talking about
the elements in their pure
forms at one bar, standard
states, and room temperature.
And if we look this up in our
textbook, we would find that
the delta h of formation for
water is negative 286
kilojoules per mole.
Similarly we can look up the
same thing, for example, for
carbon dioxide, and what we'll
find here is that our delta h
of formation that we look
up is negative 393 .
5 kilojoules per mole.
We can also look up or think
about what our delta h of
formation would be for oxygen.
Does anyone have a guess here?
Yup, it's actually
going to be zero.
Oxygen already is in its most
stable state, so any time
we're talking about an element
in their most stable state,
it's going to be zero.
That's going to be the delta
h of formation, there
is none, it's zero.
We can also look up what it was
for sugar, for glucose, c
6 h 12 o 6.
So that coming from its most
stable forms, it was the most
pure form of the elements, is
going to be negative 1260
kilojoules per mole.
All of this information has
been tabulated and is in
tables, you can refer to them,
and they're also in the back
of your textbook, so you can
refer to those in terms of
your problem-set.
So let's go ahead and solve a
problem actually using the
delta h's of formation.
Let's see if we can do any
better to coming close to the
reality for the oxidation
of glucose.
So if we're going to calculate
the delta h for the reaction
for the oxidation of glucose,
or actually for any reaction
at all, what we want to do is
take the delta h of formation
of the products and subtract
from that the delta h of
formation of the reactants.
So let's go ahead and do that.
And in terms of talking about
the oxidation of glucose, if
we talk about delta h of this
reaction, what we need to take
is 6 times delta h of formation
of c o 2, since
we're forming, that's in our
products, we're forming six
moles of c o 2.
Plus 6 times delta h formation
of h 2 o, since we're forming
six moles of h 2 o.
And we subtract from that the
heat of formation of all of
our reactants.
So we only have one mole, so we
just say delta h formation
of c 6 h 12 o 6, and then in
addition to that we have six
moles delta h formation
of oxygen, of o 2.
All right, so this is our
equation here and at this
point what we would do is we
would look up what all of the
delta h formation values
are for c o 2, h 2
o, sugar, and oxygen.
So what we would find is that
we end up having 6 times
negative 393 .
5 -- that's what we had
just looked up and
told you for c o 2.
Plus 6 times negative 285 .
8 for the water.
Minus 1 times 1260, so
it's negative 1260
for our sugar here.
And then what we're going to end
up with is having minus,
and what is it for
oxygen again?
So minus 0.
So what we end up with in terms
of the delta h for the
entire reaction here, is we end
up with negative 2816, and
it's going to be kilojoules
per mole of glucose.
All right, so let's see how this
matches up, and hopefully
you can actually remember that
this matches up actually
perfectly here.
So what we are going to see
is that, in fact, what we
calculated versus what
is experimental
is dead-on the same.
So there's actually one more
way to figure out the
enthalpies of a reaction,
I'm going to go over
it just very briefly.
And that's based on the fact
that enthalpy is a state
function, and by state function
what I mean is that
it doesn't matter how you got
from point a to point b, all
that matters is the difference
between the two.
So another example of a state
function is altitude, for
example, on a mountain.
So if you're talking about
altitude, you go from point a
to point b on the mountain, and
it doesn't matter how you
got there -- you could have
climbed all the way up the top
of the mountain, then went
back down and eventually
landed on point b.
Or you could have gone
straight from
point a to point b.
The change in altitude between
point a and point b do not
depend on the path, they're
independent of path.
So this difference right here
does not matter on how you got
there, it does not make a
difference how you got there,
altitude is a state function.
So similarly, we can say that
enthalpy is a state function
as well, if we're talking about
part reaction a here,
which has our reactants going
to our products in 2 b here.
It doesn't matter how
we got there.
We can actually calculate the
change in enthalpy at all
different points here.
All that we actually have to
worry about at the end of the
day is the difference
between a and b.
So that's what we mean
by state function.
Actually, we're not going to
have a chance to get to fully
explaining the consequence of
this, which is Hess's law,
which allows us to add and
subtract different reactions.
So what I'm going to say is the
last two problems on your
problem-set you won't have to do
because we're not going to
get a chance to cover
in class on Friday.
So I'll send out an email about
this as well, so that'll
be pushed back.
So, it will be on the exam, so
you want to do them at some
point, but you don't need to
actually turn those in.
So those are the last two
problems, I believe.